[Music]
cardiovascular disease and specifically
heart failure is the number one cause of
death in men
and women across just about every
demographic
if we had a patient with a bad heart and
we could take their heart out and
replace it with a machine
we do it all the time for the last half
century
scientists have been working tirelessly
to create a machine that can accurately
mimic the function of a beating human
heart
envisioning devices they hope will one
day rid us of the number one cause of
death in the world
every technology goes through a
sigmoidal adoption curve
five percent of people are doing it then
10 then 15
then suddenly it saturates and goes
vertical and only now
in the last decade or so have we had the
technology to make devices that
potentially could last a decade or more
if we had a practical permanent total
artificial heart it would be one of the
biggest accomplishments in modern
medicine
when it comes to heart failure there's
currently only one gold standard of
treatment
replacing the failing heart with a
healthy donor
and while there are nearly 6 000 heart
transplants done annually
there are about a million requests for
donor hearts each year
600 000 of which are in the u.s alone
so the main limitation to heart
transplantation is having a donor heart
that we can
place in a patient who's destined to die
from heart failure
dr william cohn is a heart surgeon at
the texas heart institute and an
innovator in artificial heart technology
and if you think about it it's got to be
a healthy heart from a patient who's
died in such a way that it didn't affect
their heart and that doesn't happen that
frequently
so to be able to save the lives of all
these patients
that are dying of heart failure we need
something other than the transplanted
heart
your heart's just a pump every cell in
your body
needs nutrition needs oxygen it gets
that through the blood that
goes through every blood vessel in your
body the heart is the pump that makes
the blood move
so a heart is a very very simple device
by some metrics
but incredibly complex by others
[Music]
so a lot of scientists looked at the
heart function and tried to mimic it
the really first artificial hearth was
designed by a guy named domingo loyota
brilliant argentinian scientist who was
working at the cleveland clinic and came
down to work with
michael debakey pioneering heart surgeon
in houston
and they developed a device that debacy
had implanted
in seven cows the longest one about 12
hours
while debakey was in washington dc
asking for additional funding
his then partner denton cooley implanted
it in a desperately ill human patient
haskell carp
april 4th 1969 that was the world's
first
clinical use of a total artificial heart
the possibility has now been
established as a reality the fact that
mr carp
has regained organ function in terms of
cerebral function and kidney function
indicates that its
mechanical heart is a feasibility
unfortunately the valves that they put
in this version of the heart were
breaking up the blood
the broken up blood was causing the
kidneys to fail and after
64 hours on the device they did an
emergency transplant and tragically
36 hours later died of an infection
but it showed us that that type of thing
was possible
the heart had bladders that filled and
emptied with compressed air that drove
the blood forward
one way valves made it so that when the
bladders collapsed
blood poured into the device when the
bladders filled
it went out through the great vessels
based on that technology
that device continued to evolve and
evolved into what we now have
the syncardia device which is the
world's first approved device
just like the one implanted in 1969 but
much better membranes much better valves
much better material and manufacturing
techniques
now we've just heard that the carmat
device has been approved for commercial
sale in europe
and that's great that's a step forward
but it's still approved
for temporary use syncardia and carmat
are the only approved artificial hearts
in the world right now
but they're currently approved only as
bridge to transplant devices
temporary hearts that work to keep
patients alive until a real donor heart
becomes available
the longest and artificial heart has
ever lasted in a patient
is 374 days or roughly four years
the real limitation being long-term
durability
think about it now if your heart is
beating 80 times a minute that's 132 000
times
in a day that's 42 million times in a
year
so the challenge with all the artificial
hearts that have been developed so far
is
it wears out anything that has to flex
over and over again
to make it so it never fails i think is
a tall order
the durability factor has led other
groups to rethink their approach to how
an artificial heart mimics our own
bivacor a startup from brisbane
australia that's headquartered in
houston texas
has come up with a device that hardly
resembles a human heart at all
their radical new approach has helped
them to raise more than 20 million
dollars
and has won over industry heavy hitters
like dr cohn
who serves as their chief medical
officer my name is daniel timms
i'm a mechanical engineer with a phd in
biomedical engineering
during my phd i invented the bible core
device and have
been developing that device ever since
the artificial heart that we're creating
is what's called a rotary total
artificial heart which has a spinning
disc which is magnetically levitated
within a cavity to pump the blood to
both
the lungs and to the body simultaneously
it's a similar
process to a fan where your ceiling fan
will spin
and air will come down at a constant
flow rate instead of air we're pumping
blood
but it's very similar impeller
effectively that's inside the artificial
heart
and so that approach is radically
different from utilizing
compressing sacs a spinning disc that is
magnetically levitated meaning that
there's no
touchdown of any of those moving parts
can effectively last
forever bivocor's artificial heart works
of a rapidly spinning pump technology
developed by scientists rob jarvik and
rich wampler in the mid-1980s
in their device small turbines sat
outside unhealthy hearts to assist with
blood flow to a single ventricle
tim's device builds on that idea by
using a spinning disc
or impeller to push and regulate the
flow of blood to both ventricles
the impeller inside there's a single
disc with veins
on one side to pump the blood to the
body and veins on the other side to pump
the blood to the lungs and they look
different because the requirements of
pressure are different in the body
and the lungs the magnetic levitation
system interfaces with two ring shaped
magnets that magnetic bearing
detects this rotor and if the rotor
moves further away
coils will energize to bring it closer
and if it gets too close they'll
de-energize and it'll do that 2000 times
a second to read the position
and then keep the disc levitated well
away from the casing therefore
eliminating any of the mechanical wear
bivocor is currently testing its device
in this system that circulates liquids
to replicate the functions of the human
body
there's one big question though that
they won't be able to answer before
human trials whether biva core patients
will have a pulse
while we tend to think of the pulse as
fundamental to the heart's function
vivicor's device can actually propel
blood in a continuous stream
which works fine in the lab and in
animal trials but no one knows exactly
what its effects would be on the human
body
so tims is exploring other options as
well right now the device is operating
in a continuous flow mode
but then we want to introduce
pulsatility into that system so we can
turn on
uh pulsatility in that regard
you'll see this device is running in a
pulsatile mode you know once every
every second and we're reproducing that
volatility by taking the spinning disc
and rapidly spinning it up and down up
and down once a second
and that reproduces that pulsatile
outflow that we can observe
what we then have the ability for this
device to do is even change that beat
rate
where alternatively the patient is
exercising and there might be a higher
beat rate
i'm required there and uh this is at 90
beats per minute now
resting and sleeping and so that pulse
rate will be
lower eventually bivacore intends for
these changes in heart rate to be
automatic
based on blood pressure changes that
occur when a patient moves from one type
of physical activity to another
this is a project that i've worked on
now for
almost two decades
during my undergraduate studies around
about that time my father had heart
failure
in the early days the whole goal was to
try to make something a little naively
to help his
um you know failing circulation we
decided that we'd do some of the work
in our garage or in our home my father
was a plumber so he was very
adept with circulation systems so what
we
decided to do was you know make a
prototype of this device
[Music]
so this is one of the very first
prototype iterations of the bible core
device
as you'll see here we have an ability to
put in different horseshoe magnets
on this side is where the motor can fit
inside
then of course we look inside the pump
and we can see
one of the very first impeller designs
that was
um actually made by my dad he
machined this on a mini lathe right next
to the tv so it could work on the knee
late while
watching tv although we
are now creating a device and obviously
not
in time for for him um there's many
other people out with heart failure and
you know not only does it touch the
patient with the heart failure
but uh their immediate family which you
know is something that my mum and
myself have been dealing with now for
now 15 years
um since that time so that really
catalyzed our
the motivation and the passion really to
get this
you know into those patients that need
it
bivacor is currently working with the
fda undergoing durability and animal
studies
they're also poised for their first
human implant to take place in 2022
meanwhile france-based carma received
approval from the eu
at the end of 2020 and has started
manufacturing its hearts for commercial
sale
hopes are high that karma's heart will
prove longer lasting than earlier
artificial hearts
and the company intends for its product
to eventually become a permanent
replacement
not just a stop gap
as promising as these technologies are
one big remaining downside
is the briefcase sized power packs that
have to stay permanently connected to
the hearts through the patient's skin
advancements like extending battery life
and replacing cable drivelines with
wireless charging technology
would have to be realized before an
artificial heart patient's freedom is
truly on par
with a healthy transplant recipient
you could argue that we're still in this
low phase we haven't gone vertical yet
because there are four or five thousand
pumps implanted a year
but four hundred thousand people dying
of heart failure
it's a whole bunch of technical forces
that are converging on
having an artificial heart that lasts a
long time
that doesn't have a wire through the
skin and then
maybe heart failure won't be the number
one cause of death in the world
you